[Musica]
[Applauso]
non voglio pensare che la soluzione per
la nostra specie sia la migrazione verso
altri pianeti
nutro ancora la speranza che attraverso
il cibo si possono aprire gli occhi alle
persone e renderle consapevoli che la
terra è l'unica nostra vera casa più che
di altruismo estremo si tratta di un
passaggio inevitabile per chi come me fa
questo mestiere far capire l'importanza
che l'alimentazione a negli equilibri
del sistema globale
ognuno però deve dare il proprio
contributo per tentare di fermare questo
processo inevitabile di autodistruzione
perché ormai palesemente sotto i nostri
occhi la prima cosa da fare è
salvaguardare le specie esistenti ad
esempio solo l'italia è lo 0 5 della
superficie del mondo con 12 milioni di
ettari coltivati e per molti rappresenta
l'eccellenza dell'agroalimentare nel
mondo la nostra grande bellezza e la
biodiversità
siamo l'unica bell'inizio nel mondo dove
l'incontro tra i venti del mare del sud
e quelli delle montagne del nord produce
un microclima unico deteniamo il primato
europeo ospitando oltre 67 mila specie
di piante animali circa il 43 per cento
di quelle presenti in europa abbiamo
circa 7 mila specie di flora vascolare
dei vegetali commestibili
abbiamo il più alto numero di vitigni
autoctoni e cultivar di olive al mondo
troppo spesso nel nome del dio denaro e
con la scusa di sfamare il mondo
abbiamo distrutto tutto eliminato
foreste intere per lasciare spazio a
colture intensive inquinato i mari senza
ritegno e senza pensarci due volte
e questa distruzione la perpetriamo
anche attraverso i nostri piccoli gesti
quotidiani e la facciamo con un tale
indifferenza come se questo non avesse
nulla a che vedere con le nostre piccole
realtà come se non ci fossero
ripercussioni all'interno dei nostri
micromondi magari con ingenuo e
infantile speranza che un giorno tutto
si sarebbe sistemato da sé niente di più
sbagliato niente di più egoistico
mi distrugge sapere che da qualche parte
nel mondo magari più vicino di quanto
possiamo pensare un'altra specie si sta
estinguendo per sempre milioni di anni
di evoluzione buttate via così in un
attimo
certo è un processo naturale ma questo
nostro egoismo lo sta accelerando in
modo vertiginoso e tanto da stimare un
migliaio di specie estinte ogni anno
addirittura il biologo wilson
dell'harvard university stima fino a
30.000 specie perse creando ovviamente
un effetto domino e dunque che cosa
rimarrà le generazioni future
ai nostri figli di questo passo
niente io sogno anzi ne ho tanti ma
questo è quello a cui tengo di più
il più importante è ovviamente più
difficile da realizzare si chiama a
grida è tradotto in sogno di agricoltura
come dovrebbe essere l'allevamento
dell'agricoltura in un contesto di
sostenibilità ambientale e alimentare
per prima cosa bisogna ripristinare un
sistema capillare di coltivazioni il
metodo naturale
ad oggi i contadini si vedono costretti
a lavorare in commissionare il sistema
agroalimentare imposto dalle lobby dalle
grandi industrie sementiere e
farmaceutiche nel nome della
produttività garantita noi cuochi da
quando decidiamo di indossare quella
giacca bianca ancora prima di diventare
chef
dobbiamo capire che siamo degli
ambasciatori del cibo
abbiamo il dovere di sostenere questi
piccoli produttori agricoltori e
artigiani che vogliono o vorrebbero
lavorare nel modo giusto magari contro
tutto e tutti è necessario dare loro la
speranza incentivarli spronarli e non
cadere in schiavitù del metodo
convenzionale
dobbiamo unirci a tutti i livelli e
lavorare su questo punto che è il fulcro
di qualsiasi cucina la migliore materia
prima si ottiene nel migliore stato
naturale la migliore materia prima si
ottiene nel miglior stato naturale più
contadini lavoreranno innaturale
con specie autoctone da semi antichi non
manipolati ottenendo risultati
sorprendenti da subito più continueranno
a fare quello che già fanno e
coinvolgeranno altri colleghi a
convertirsi e avremo così più facilmente
per tutti un cibo veramente sano genuino
e ricco di valore nutritivo e non
costerà più una follia perché non ci
saranno più passaggi intermedi grazia
una filiera corta direttamente dalla
terra alla tavola e il consumatore
diventerà il famoso co produttore ovvero
un acquirente consapevole che grazie
alla sua spesa intelligente aiuta questo
corretto sistema alimentare
ecco la risposta a tutto il consumatore
come perno centrale di questo sistema
alimentare e la cucina deve essere
tramite che lancia messaggi importanti
per sensibilizzare più persone possibili
partendo dalla tavola ad esempio tutti i
giorni perché creare una connessione tra
la terra e il cliente è un nostro dovere
raccontare storie di produttori e uomini
e territori significa tramandare restare
autentici vuol dire avere un'identità
portare avanti una missione che vada
oltre la semplice professione è un atto
di fede e nel mio caso la cucina
italiana era madre di tutte le cucine e
sarà nel tempo la gastronomia di
riferimento unità e organizzata nella
educazione e divulgazione di un metodo
di lavoro per riconoscibile nuovo
originale ma ricco delle tradizioni da
cui noi tutti proveniamo
la vera artigianalità delle nostre madri
nelle preparazioni culinarie e la fonte
le stagioni ei prodotti della terra sono
l'ispirazione perché la nostra è una
cucina casalinga su questo siamo tutti
d'accordo
da sempre però ricca di grandi scambi
culturali e per questo siamo
inconsciamente ricchi di un patrimonio
inestimabile ma dobbiamo educarli
divulgare costantemente ecco alcuni
esempi gastronomici proposti nelle mie
tavole oltre al progetto a creare
brasato crusoe perché la conoscenza di
quello che mangiamo non è mai troppa e a
volte le cose più scontate sono invece
su quelle su cui dobbiamo riflettere
questo piatto infatti nasce quando mia
moglie stava spiegando lo stracotto di
vacca burlina al tavolo e le viene
chiesto una cottura media
ecco che la cui parte la provocazione
con quello che visivamente vi sembrano
uno spezzatino 1 stracotto in realtà è
una tartare di manzo nappata confondono
un vicolo di manzo e liquirizia aria
fritta
un benvenuto di riflessione per rendere
partecipe le persone che stiamo vivendo
un momento storico dove nulla è sempre
più importante contenuti volatili
scorrono senza significato
dimenticando sempre di più i veri valori
della vita
fon for food nell'altro nostro locale di
venezia se lasci giu il cellulare al
desk quindi telo sequestriamo ti
offriamo l'aperitivo così
incentiviamo le persone a parlarsi di
più a concentrarsi sul cibo sulla
sacralità della tavola e del convivio
questo per darvi alcuni esempi pratici
su cosa riusciamo a trasmettere noi
cuochi se siamo uniti possiamo ancora
svincolarci da questa illusione di
libertà che ci viene propinata ogni
giorno per appagare le nostre coscienze
la cosa più importante
oggi in mezzo questa catastrofe
ambientale alimentare e saper
selezionare selezionare i prodotti
giusti i produttori giusti le persone
giuste spendete del tempo per acquistare
sano per farvi un orto vivete
consapevoli
siate padroni della vostra vita nel
profondo la libertà vera va ben oltre
quello che vi sembra di poter ottenere
con il denaro
la salvaguardia del nostro pianeta
inizia da una grande forza di volontà
interiore e da uno spirito estremamente
libero
[Applauso]